what makes you an attractive woman to a
man like what are your qualities what do
you bring to the table I
guess I'm smart I know what I want I
make a lot of
money I am huge on family I think that's
super
important
[Music]
um
uh I think I'm pretty
goodlook um I want I don't want to be
cocky so I'm not going to like say too
much um it's okay to say you're good
looking you're
beautiful
um I
uh I know like I'm very Street Smart
like I know how to fix cars so that I
feel like that's a good thing to know um
like my dad raised me on like home
projects because my mom has like this
never ending honeydew list for for him
um so like it's painting the walls and
fixing the heat in the house and let's
go work on my El Camino and look under
the hood for six hours and stuff like
that and that's how I was raised how
much is um a service adviser make it
Infinity um so where they made a lot of
money huh I wasn't aware that they made
a lot of
money um I make 75 grand a year okay so
that's considerably more than your
$45,000 requirement that you're looking
for from a guy that's a lot less than
what you
make yes but I mean money's not really
I'm not really worried
about if
they're I don't know it's hard to say I
mean my ex was in the military so he
didn't make that much money per year
because they don't like you know their
paychecks are weird because taxes aren't
taken out and all of that strange stuff
so um other than that I really didn't
know about any of my other ex's
finances so all the things that you
described there like I make a lot of
money I'm I'm I'm competent you know I
can pop the hood in the El Camino and do
all this sort of stuff like like you
named a lot of very like you basically
described a dude like you describe the
dude that you want to be with
right do you think that guys are looking
for that a
woman uh I hope so because that's what
I'm good
at well I think that that's one of the
great mistakes that you know women make
today if I'm being honest here is that
they have believed the comforting lies
that have been sold to them for the last
several decades where it's like you go
girl climb the corporate ladder make
lots of money learn how to you know swap
out a spark plug in an El Camino um you
know you've got quality SK like you're
basically becoming a version of a man
and men today especially the High
Caliber guys that you're contemplating
right you know successful muscular you
know Can Make It Rain sort of thing
competent funny captivating you know
we'll do things with you um they're not
looking to date a version of
themselves
MH do you think that that might be
repelling some guys away
it could be
but that's
fine well I mean if you want to attract
a man and have a family wouldn't it make
sense to calibrate yourself to what
you're looking for I'm not saying you
have to I'm just offering the
recommendation yes that makes
sense right it's like you know you can
take the analogy of a car dealership
right you're not going to screw on a BMW
oil filter onto an Infinity it's just
not going to fit it's not going to work
out it's going to leak everywhere engine
will blow
right similar sort of thing right like
maybe you're the oil filter getting
screwed onto the engine block you know
the guys the engine block and you're
you're linking up that sort of
way yeah they together that makes sense
and that's where like the notion of the
blue jobs and the pink jobs sort of you
know comes from is that men and women
are better together than they are apart
if they can collaborate and they can
sort of like fit each other needs and
wants but what you're describing there
earlier on was basically a dude right
successful makes lots of money competent
I get things
done you
know what do you think guys
want uh I'm I'm a bad person to answer
that question I don't
know it's it's kind of an important
question to ask if you know you want to
attract a guy and you want to get
married right see here's the interesting
thing right like you're disappointed
that the last guy cheated on you he
proposed did all this stuff then you
know stepped out on you you know just
ghosted you and updated his Instagram to
a new check um you're pining for a
serious relationship guy that doesn't
live at home with Mom that's captivating
that has a career not a job all that
good stuff wouldn't it make sense to
calibrate yourself to attract
that yes you know like if I want to
attract bees then I'll use honey if I
want to attract flies then I'll use [__]
sort of thing like you know you want
calibrate to what it is that you're
trying to draw and attract yeah like I
tell guys all the time like I can tell
you exactly what women want and I can
tell you exactly what you need to do to
get the women that you want right but I
don't think anybody's out there being
honest telling women what these guys
want that you're
describing yeah because they don't say
that again it's because they don't know
did you say women not telling women I
think because women don't even know what
they want I don't think women are even
honest with each other you know that
yeah no I think they don't know
genuinely I yeah well I think that they
do know to some degree but I don't think
that women are being honest with each
other because they because they'll
always fluff each other up you know like
girl you know you're beautiful you know
you've got a great smile you know the
that the other thing the right guy will
just come along right like that's what
you know that's what they'll like what
moms tell Sons you know like these
husband Sons is you're a really good guy
the right girl will come along just be
yourself right and again this is a guy
that that's like a Walmart greeter you
know for example just be yourself the
right girl will sort of come along right
so I wonder if you put any thought into
sort of calibrating yourself to what the
guy that you're describing that you want
so that you can attract him right so
that you can become honey to get the be
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out